et c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus à la une ce soir la
fin du sommet de la cedeao à accra des
sanctions sont envisagées contre la
guinée et le burkina faso si les
transitions ne sont pas rapidement mise
en place en revanche pas de consensus
trouvé sur le mali nous n'en parlerons
avec une fleur lespiau notre
correspondante à bamako qui est avec
nous en plateau en ethiopie c'est peut
être un premier pas vers la paix les
rebelles tigre et accepte le
cessez-le-feu proposé par le premier
ministre habib ahmed une trêve
humanitaire illimité à effet immédiat
après plus d'un an et demi de combats
acharnés
les faits la situation se complique un
peu plus en tunisie de nombreux secteurs
de l'économie sont impactés par la
guerre en ukraine reportage à suivre
dans ce journal
ils se sont réunis à huis clos les chefs
d'état de la cedeao étaient à accra ce
vendredi et le programme des discussions
était assez dense crise en guinée au
burkina faso la cedeao réclame la
libération immédiate du président kaboré
en résidence surveillée depuis deux mois
maintenant et veut une transition plus
rapide la junte guinéenne al de son côté
jusqu'au 25 avril pour mettre en place
une transition démocratique faute de
quoi des sanctions seront appliquées et
du côté du mali et bien ça coince
toujours les médiations avec la junte
sont jusque là restées dans l'impasse
une fleur vous êtes notre correspondante
à bamako vous êtes avec nous à paris la
situation reste donc inchangé pour le
mali oui tout à fait et mounia le bras
de fer entre la cedeao et les autorités
de transition malienne se poursuit vous
l'avez dit ce sommet s'est tenu à huis
clos cet après midi entre les chefs
d'état de la cedeao en sommet auquel
étaient conviés le président de la
transition le colonel assis meego rita
qui a refusé de se rendre physiquement à
accra il avait tenté de dépêcher une
délégation ministérielle qui n'a pas été
acceptée par la cedeao et devait donc
suivre cette réunion par visioconférence
le principal sujet qui devait être
discuté était celui de l'alloeu et
progressive des sanctions de la cedeao
qui pèse sur le mali depuis plus de deux
mois les autorités de transition et la
cédéao devaient se mettre d'accord sur
un chronogramme électoral clair et
acceptable pour la cedeao qui
permettrait d'organiser le retour des
civils au pouvoir jusqu alors les
autorités de transition tabler sur le
prolongement de la transition jusqu'à
cinq ans une proposition refusée par la
cedeao en visite à bamako la semaine
dernière qui proposait un délai allant
de douze à seize mois à la suite de
cette visite à 6 me go rita avait
proposé un nouveau délai incompressible
de 24 mois mais là la cedeao qui
souhaitent à des transitions plus rapide
en pour le mali le burkina faso la
guinée
anne fleur quel impact ces sanctions sur
la population malienne alors ces
sanctions elles sont jugées depuis leur
mise en place le 9 janvier comme
illégales et illégitimes par le premier
ministre malien choguel kokalla maïga
ce sont des sanctions lourdes pour le
portefeuille des maliens qui pâtissent
de la hausse des prix de certaines
denrées et produits
provoquée par la fermeture des
frontières et par l'embargo financier de
la cedeao pour y faire face le
gouvernement malien a mis en place le
plafonnement du prix de certains
produits il a également favorisé les
routes commerciales avec la guinée
également sous sanctions de la cedeao et
avec la mauritanie qui n en fait pas
partie des mesures qui ne sont pas
suffisantes et tenables sur le long
terme d'après plusieurs chefs
d'entreprise et commerçants avec qui
j'ai pu échanger avant de quitter bamako
la plupart se plaignent de la difficulté
d'approvisionnement au mali qui est
rappelons le un pays enclavé pour
certains d'entre eux leurs stocks
restent bloqués par exemple à dakar au
sénégal
ils s'inquiètent également du départ de
bon nombre d'investisseurs et
investisseurs économiques et étrangers
mais également de l'isolément politique
du mali qui par ailleurs continuent de
faire face à la dégradation du contexte
sécuritaire sur l'ensemble de son
territoire merci beaucoup une fleur pour
pour eux point sur la situation
au mali on continue parler de cette
situation sécuritaire justement ils se
sont affrontés sans relâche durant 17
mois l'armée éthiopienne et les rebelles
tigréens s'accordent sur un
cessez-le-feu immédiat le gouvernement
dhabi ahmed avait tendu la main aux
insurgés hier une pause dans les combats
pour permettre l'acheminement de l'aide
humanitaire car le pays est à bout les
précisions de chars pellegrin edwige et
vol ouamane issa
après dix sept mois de guerre les
rebelles du tigre et ont décidé à leur
tour de baisser les armes un cessez le
feu à effet immédiat qui fait suite à
l'annoncé quelques heures plus tôt par
le gouvernement éthiopien d'une trêve
humanitaire illimitée
améliorer le sort des personnes touchées
par le conflit est une priorité absolue
et une responsabilité que le
gouvernement prend au sérieux une mesure
saluée par la communauté internationale
la trêve doit permettre l'acheminement
de l'aide humanitaire dans le nord du
pays où selon l'onu 9 millions de
personnes seraient en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire
jusqu'à présent les combats empêcher le
passage des convois sur la seule voie
encore opérationnels qui relie la région
de l'afar à mékhé les capitales du tigre
et le dernier convoi est passé le 15
décembre dernier à addis abeba la
perspective d'un arrêt des combats
rassure ya là de quoi tu nous avons
mangé notre pain quotidien seulement
s'il ya la paix c'est très bien qu'il y
ait des négociations pour la paix est
surtout pour nos frères et soeurs dans
le nord
depuis 2001 les rebelles et les forces
pro gouvernementales ne cessent de
s'affronter en cause la décision du
premier ministre habib ahmed de déloger
le front de libération du peuple du
tigré une faction rebelle qui contestent
son autorité
les affrontements ont mené à plus de 400
mille déplacés internes
et on revient la situation sécuritaire
au mali je vous le disais hier selon la
minus pas près de 600 civils maliens ont
perdu la vie l'an dernier en raison des
violences dans le pays face à la menace
les maliens n'ont souvent d'autre choix
que de fuir leur village certains ont
trouvé refuge au niger l'onu fille a
établi siens quand à ouallam où s'est
rendu de notre correspondant harold
girard
il y a moins de trois mois après une
attaque maimouna mohamed quitte son
village situé dans la zone de ménaka au
mali
j'entendais avant des villages qui se
faisait attaquer les bandits tuer les
gens et voler leur bétail mais cette
fois ci c'était nous
j'ai dû fuir avec mes deux enfants sans
mon mari
ça nous a pris une journée entière pour
venir ici à ouallam on a dormi dans la
brousse avant de venir au camp
près de douze mille réfugiés sont
hébergés dans le camp de ouallam qui est
en place depuis 2020 une partie des
réfugiés préfèrent poursuivre le chemin
jusqu'à la capitale nigérienne hors des
camps certains tente de rebâtir leur
communauté
zac ou karimou était chef d'un village
malien situé près de la frontière entre
les deux pays
bonjour que la paix soit avec vous
les gens avec qui j'ai fui jusqu'ici ils
me considèrent toujours comme leur chef
mais aux alentours et puis dans niamey
on ne se sent même pas pris en compte
comme à trouer maimouna la plupart des
réfugiés maliens doivent traverser le
nord de la région de tillabéri l'une des
zones les plus dangereuses du pays ils
ont touché ce qui était peut-être le la
zone la plus proche de l'éruption
volcanique pourrait être à la périphérie
mais sinon des attaques à walla sont
possibles des attaques sont possibles
partout dans toutes les villes du niger
et dans toutes les villes des trois pays
bas air burkina faso mali qui c'est la
même situation
au mali les récents affrontements entre
groupes armés ont une nouvelle fois
poussé plusieurs milliers d'habitants à
l'exil au moins soixante mille maliens
qui ont fui cette violence vivent
actuellement au niger
et on en vient aux nombreuses
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine sur
le continent direction la tunisie où
plusieurs secteurs sont touchés le
secteur agricole en premier lieu le
tourisme aussi mais également celui de
l'éducation souvenez-vous des centaines
d'étudiants ont dû être rapatriés
d'urgence ce fut le cas pour dounia nos
correspondants lilia blaise et âme dit
les lits sont allés à sa rencontre
dounia et sa soeur étaient admis pro sud
est de l'ukraine où l étudier la
médecine dentaire elles ont dû quitter
précipitamment le pays al'annonce de
l'attak russe c'est c'est notre ami il a
employé où il y avait des bombardements
je pense tout le monde était paniqué et
banques étant fermées les gens veulent
retirer de l'argent partout il y avait
des gens qui
qui font les courses qui prend de l'eau
et de la nourriture aujourd'hui dounia
suit ses cours en ligne mais avec
l'intensification des combats la
poursuite de son année universitaire
paraît compromise un avenir incertain
pour les étudiants tunisiens mais aussi
pour les agriculteurs du pays la tunisie
importe près de 50 % de ses besoins en
céréales et en blé d'ukraine dont une
partie sert à l'alimentation concentré
du bétail et de la volaille cet éleveur
de la région de boussalem dans le nord
du pays craint de ne plus être
approvisionnées c'est le concentré c'est
le soja le maïs
lusinchi nous fournit le concentré nous
dit qu'elle a des stocks pour deux mois
maximum après tout dépend de l'évolution
de la guerre en ukraine ce donc très
très flou
le pays souffre actuellement de
l'inflation avec une augmentation des
prix sur plusieurs dans les alimentaire
et le lait pourrait bientôt être
concernés la qualité et la quantité du
lait dépend de se concentrer donc si ce
concentré manque la production de lait
va en pâtir et ensuite cela se
répercutera sur les prix du lait et de
la viande rouge autre secteur clé de
l'économie tunisienne comme le tourisme
en pleine préparation de la reprise
après la pandémie anticipe déjà la perte
du marché russe ils représentaient six
cent cinquante mille touristes en 2019
jusqu'au début de la guerre il ya eu des
réservations et dès le début de la
guerre les réservations se sont arrêtés
et
aujourd'hui c'est le flou total un
manque de visibilité dû à la fermeture
des espaces aériens aux avions mousse
mais les professionnels du tourisme
tunisien sont résilients ce n'est pas la
première crise qu'il traverse depuis la
révolution de 2011
les élections partielles ce samedi au
zimbabwe c'est le premier scrutin depuis
la présidentielle de 2000 18 remportés
par emmerson mnangagwa ce dernier a mis
fin à l'ère moga b caroline dumay nous
explique les enjeux de ce rendez vous
électoral
est une élection partielle 133 sièges
sont à pourvoir à l'assemblée nationale
mais surtout au sein des autorités
locales mais c'est une élection cruciale
pour les zimbabwéens pour l'opposition
surtout nelson chamisa le leader de
l'opposition qui avaient perdu de
justesse des élections présidentielles
contre l'actuel président mounanga goy
en 2018 est bien à créer un nouveau
parti et il va tester sa popularité il
entend bien gagner les présidentielles
de l'année prochaine élection test donc
avec une campagne électorale violentes
ou plusieurs dizaines d'opposants ont
été arrêtés à signaler que c'est un
scrutin à huit clos car aucun
journaliste international n'a été
accréditée à la direction la guinée est
là le pays est secoué ces derniers jours
par la divulgation d'un enregistrement
audio on y entend le président déchu
alpha condé son ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères et son médecin
personnel ont été arrêtés avaient été
arrêtés les deux hommes ont finalement
été relâchés jeudi
plus de détails avec malik diakité notre
correspondant à conakry
après de longues heures d'auditions ce
jeudi devant le procureur de la
république l'aide de personnalités ont
été placés sous contrôle judiciaire ils
doivent se présenter deux fois par mois
devant un juge d'instruction
ibrahima kalil kaba ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères m bemba kaba médecin
personnel du président deux chu sont
soupçonnées d'être impliquées dans la
fuite aux dons enregistrement audio de
l'ex président alpha condé dans cet
enregistrement audio justement on entend
alpha condé donné des instructions à ses
partisans de réorganiser son parti
politique
d'empêcher ses opposants farouches
notamment cellou dalein diallo et sidya
touré d'accéder au pouvoir ces
arrestations avaient été dénoncés par le
rpg arc en ciel le parti de l'ex
président alpha condé aujourd'hui
totalement divisée pas une guerre de
succession
elle fait la fierté de la côte d'ivoire
olivier yacé est arrivé troisième du
concours de miss monde un accueil
triomphal lui a été réservé à son retour
à abidjan la mannequin de 23 ans avait
pu compter sur le soutien de sa famille
et des officiels pour préparer la
compétition au pavillon présidentiel
vous le voyez ils étaient tous là pour
la féliciter ses projets pour la suite
poursuivre son mandat de miss côte
d'ivoire et continue à promouvoir son
pays à travers le monde on écoute
olivier yacé
énorme vous voyez je n'aime pas les
manger
tellement heureux de retourner dans mon
pays ni pour mes parents de voir des
amis
les autorités avaient pressé
en ce monde
et c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
je vous retrouve dans moins d'une heure
pour une nouvelle édition à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la côte d'ivoire dispose de ressources
abondantes en haut mais elle connaît un
important déficit de distribution d'eau
potable à ces populations c'est dans ce
cadre que le gouvernement ivoirien a
développé le programme eau pour tous qui
vise à mettre fin aux pénuries d'eau sur
les localités les plus gravement
touchées par cette problématique les
solutions qui ont été retenus par les
autorités ivoiriennes sont les us et des
unités compactes décentralisée ce sont
des stations de traitement d'eau
métallique préfabriqués innovantes
notamment par leur rapidité de
déploiement elle s'installe en un temps
record mais aussi un coût extrêmement
compétitif et nécessite peu de génie
civil peut d'empreintes au sol elles
peuvent être équipé d'une toiture
solaire et de ce fait elles peuvent
présenter un coût de production d'eau
potable réduit le programme eau pour
tous il a permis de bâtir un accès
amélioré à l'eau potable pour près d'un
million d'ivoiriens sur 32 localités
différentes à travers le pays le
programme a aussi eu pour conséquence de
lever les corvées d'eau ce qui a permis
aux femmes de pouvoir prendre du temps
pour s'atteler à l'entrepreneuriat et
aussi pour les enfants de son consacrer
pleinement à l'école et on le sait le
développement de l'entrepreneuriat des
femmes et l'éducation sont les piliers
du développement de l'afrique de demain
à travers nos solutions nous contribuons
à accélérer l'accès à l'eau potable à
l'hygiène et à l'assainissement en
milieu urbain mais aussi en milieu rural
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]